Let's say that instead of going 10 m/s, this train is going 2  10⁸ m/s.
Remember, the speed of light c is 3  10⁸ m/s. So the train is moving at 2/3 the speed of light.
Obviously, no train could actually do that--well, no train except for the train of physics.
Okay and let's get this guy out of here. Things are getting dangerous on this train.
Let's put him down here by the side of the tracks where he can safely watch the train as it goes by.
Let's also imagine this train has one of those really cool and powerful train headlights.
So we know that the speed of the train is 2  10⁸ m/s relative to the ground on this person standing there
and the speed of light is 3  10⁸ m/s, now what I want to know
at what speed is the light approach Phil and I've named our guy down here Phil.
And I'll give you a hint, it's something times 10⁸m/s. It's either 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8 or 9.
And you just have to answer the appropriate number here.